hola nobody say hi my name is Edward and
I come from Ecuador today I'd like to
explore the city of Bielefeld with you
if you know if you look amaze me the
thing I like most is this autumn the
colors red orange and yellow are simply
beautiful and look they're everywhere Oh
brilliant
Portola
get off fede well now that's out of
defeating one of the urban arts I
haven't seen it in Ecuador but here it's
everywhere let's go look at it
what was that Louie
now this is super cute
there's no plasma loss per se but I
think having color on the walls is very
positive good that people leave it there
in Germany excuse me I have a question
where do I find the farmhouse Museum
we're here in the city park and you have
to follow the road up there keep
following it and you'll find it
hello hello excuse me what is this
exactly this is a flax mill a horse
would be hitched up here and it would
walk in a circle powering the mill Khun
Danai try it out you can see how the
mill worked and what the Millers job was
like excuse me can you take a picture of
me Thanks
or that thing will book with you I'm
getting hungry let's go find something
to eat come with me
when provecho
artists come with significant brain
we're on kessler blink square and we'd
like to show you that Germans do know
how to live look at them all enjoying
the sunshine
Dante's I'm what we saw
instead I will team up at the last stop
is Spartanburg castle let's go see it
I was
so now if the matter this is a marvelous
view of the city yo KD SP determine its
better time to say goodbye I hope you've
enjoyed our adventure in Bielefeld see
you soon